Jimmy Sports a replete with dramatic
changes of emotions in a tick like that
can you just take us through from the
Elation of seeing it called a three-shot
foul making the three shots and then
that final Celtic sequence basketball
for you basketball is fine it's very
very very entertaining
um but that's that's a good basketball
and I think I believe as we all do like
you're gonna get the same test until you
pass it I swear we're in the same
position last year and um we can do it I
know that we will do it we gotta go on
the road and and win in a very very very
tough environment but we're capable of
it so
get busy
Jimmy you're all about the kind of thing
even Keel through the ups and the Downs
how do you as a leader kind of try to
keep this team mentally ended after a
loss like this uh let them know that
um
as good or as bad as we played tonight
we still lost so we still got a job to
do at the end of the day and we will be
in this thing together
um home away on the road and if
um like I told the guys on the bench I
told the guys in the locker room that um
if I play better we're not even in this
position honestly speaking and I will be
better and that's what makes me smile
because those guys Follow My Lead so
when I'm playing better I think we're
playing better as a whole
do you want me to follow up on that I
mean that's obviously one of the
craziest endings in the history of the
game how do you get everybody through
the emotional hurdle of losing in the
final second I mean I tell her ain't
nothing that you can do about it now all
you can do is move on
um
but I'm I'm honestly I'm proud of of the
guys to never give up fight to the very
end and given us a chance to win this
basketball game
didn't go our way
part of it
it hasn't been our going our way a lot
this year so this is nothing new
um we got to go on the road and do
something special but we got a special
group so why not at BS
Jimmy it's been a long playoffs maybe
even you know given the nature of the
series longer than maybe you even
expected how do you just continue to
push through from a physical standpoint
I mean we pride ourselves on being able
to do that
um I don't know the quote but spoke
probably does the most well-conditioned
most professional name it where all of
that
um this is what we we do what we do
every single day in all season in the
preseason during the regular season four
is to be able to be tired and still
figure out a way to win be tired still
be able to execute
um we we have to be able to do that now
of all times
will
uh Jimmy over the last few years you've
somehow been involved in some of the
craziest playoff bounces endings
um was there any part of you walking up
floor like I can't believe this is
happening again nope I gotta figure out
a way and the greatest part is I don't
got too much to do
um we're gonna do it as a unit every
single time
um and we're going to be in this thing
together I know that for a fact you know
when we huddled up after the game
after a tough life like this one
everybody's smiling because we know
we're very capable of it I'm telling you
and we're not going to let up I'm not
going to let anybody quit I'm not going
to let our guys quit I don't give a damn
what happens we're gonna go in there
we're gonna win
Jimmy are you uh Nostradamus because
last year May 29 2022 you said at this
stage and said that we're going to get
it done and we have what it takes
um why do you still feel that way
[Music]
um
because we got some good basketball
players on this team got some good
people that work hard they do things the
right way and they put the team first
and want to win at the end of the day
that's all that you can ask for from
anybody especially my teammates and we
have a great group
we got some guys that don't quit some
guys as
that have have had a long road to get to
this point so why give up now you know
this is the stage that we're on the
stage is set this when a light to the
brightest and um my God's gonna show up
you mentioned needing to play better do
you feel like there's anything Boston's
doing differently kind of these last few
games specifically on you and what do
you kind of feel that is
nah I just missed shots
just got to make them you know
continually hit the open guy stay
aggressive
and um
continue to lead the way for our guys
they definitely follow my lead I will I
will say that they follow bam lead as
well but especially me so if I'm
level-headed through the good and
through the bad they will be as well
and so I'm gonna smile I'm gonna go home
and play some space I don't care what
nobody say everything will be okay next
question you mentioned being
level-headed the night the night going
as it was for you individually what what
were you thinking about what was your
mindset in those last five minutes and
then that final stretch that you feel
like you found some answers uh I feel
like I made some shots that's the game
as a whole but um I know the work that I
put into it I know the work that we put
into it and I know the confidence and
the faith that my coaches and teammates
and this entire organization has in
myself and everybody else on this roster
we're not going to change we're going to
keep doing punches with the best of them
we're gonna see what we end up
um but like I said if I'm better from
Jump Street we're not even in that
position so everything that happened
tonight if I don't go five for 21 and
turn the ball over and all of this good
stuff
it's a different story I got on a
different hat up here and we're getting
ready to go to the finals